foreign
City Florida hi Anthony welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey thanks for having me on I'm grateful
to uh have the opportunity to talk to
you and John sure how can we help I got
a got a question just wanted to get some
opinion have some men speak some
knowledge into this uh my wife and I
want to own the campground someday um
we've come to this we call it a vocation
we want to own one and we don't know
what that's going to look like as far as
something that we would fund fully with
cash to acquire a campground like an RV
Park Campground or if you get a loan
take on that to do so
so this is like a dream in the future
yes okay cool
how old are you guys
I had to think about that for a second
I'm 30. no I was 28. okay cool when you
turn 30 you hear I mean start losing
your hearing yeah I'm in your memory
right away and your speech patterns
exactly um so why hey why camping man
what is it about camping
um well we both love it
um it's it's funny I'm like kind of a
jack of all trades master of none you
know I'd like to do everything and we've
been spending a lot of time at night you
know talking about what we want to do
with our future and we've settled on
this idea that yeah this is something
that could really get the gears turning
for us and keep us busy and we work
really well together and we'd like to to
do it together and we plan to like live
there too so like we see ourselves
living on this on the campground or at
least in close proximity absorbing and
you know taking on the lifestyle of
being Campground owners gotcha
okay
well the first time you run a business
of any kind
uh you start finding out that you didn't
know what you didn't know
there's all these little surprises that
go
I had no idea and they're right yep you
had no idea that's why we got you and uh
you're gonna discover that regardless of
what kind of business you own the first
time you own a business uh and run a
business and it's more than just keeping
the toilets cleaned in this case or the
electrical hookups working or whatever
whatever whatever jack of all trades
things you got all this other stuff
called accounting and marketing and
Collections and payment systems and oh a
website because that's how everyone does
everything now right oh maybe even an
app right and so yeah that's got a lot
that's a long way from uh running wiring
to the picnic shed okay and so you know
there's a lot of different skills you're
going to have to have running a business
that that you need to develop over time
and you don't want to discover those
with big hairy payments coming at your
face every month
I would rather you discover those more
gently than that so let's say that since
this is just a dream at this point let's
just adapt what some middle steps are
you're wanting to go from zero to a
hundred and one Leap and how can we do
this in the middle and I'll give you an
example I don't borrow money and I'm not
going to tell you to borrow money so
we're going to work our way through
there because I'm not I'm not that
doesn't mean I'm a dream killer either I
want you to live a dream but I don't
want your dream to be a nightmare so I
love in your case you love campgrounds I
love real estate
and um the a building that we moved into
a 55 000 square feet was a five million
dollar building and that was
um a uh 20 years ago I think something
like that uh let's just call it 20 years
ago and we didn't have five million
dollars but I really really wanted to
own this building kind of like you want
to own a campground you're following me
yes okay so what did I do I leased it
with an option to purchase it for five
years I didn't have
a half a million dollars much less five
million dollars but I started collecting
all the Nickels out of the corner of the
couch for the next five years and barely
scraped together the money at the last
minute and exercise the option after
five years thank God I did because by
then the building was worth 13 million
and I bought it for five so what's known
as a freaking deal right and but I did
not borrow money and I was telling God
all along while I was looking for the
nickels in the corner of the couch if
you don't send the money I'm not buying
this because I'm not going to borrow
money period
and me and God had a lot of
conversations about that so I kind of
had to lay my guidelines out but during
that time I learned a lot about that
building we learned that the former
owner had not taken care of the roof and
the former owner had not taken care of
the heat and air and we learned that the
heat and air was from another century
and we had to go in and rework a bunch
of that and boiler you know baling wire
and duct tape uh how does this run
parallel to what you're saying maybe a
way to do something similar might be go
to work for Campground
be the general manager and maybe they
provide housing and you stay there and
you run the whole thing for an absentee
owner and that includes you doing the
repairs and you learning how to do the
accounting and you learning from the
owner how he did marketing for the past
20 years because he was doing this stuff
when you were knee-high to
nothing
and uh let's get in there and just get
it all over you a little bit and you
might discover you freaking hate it but
you might discover it's even better than
you thought and this is like awesome and
then you might be able to option it and
buy it from him with the profits
instead of with Dad
okay I'm making up a dream scenario but
I'd rather make up one of those and you
go get an SBA loan and call me up four
months later and go I'm broke oh by the
way covet hit and they don't allow
camping anymore
yeah because that never happens
I like the slower move into it like you
guys say when I watch so like you don't
want to jump or leap into it because
we're both gainfully employed now and
we're just thinking of the options how
do we keep it but I mean let's let's
just say what do you make a year
uh combined we're about one no no what
do you make for taxes 82. okay well
let's say he paid you 60 to run the
campground you took a pay cut but you
got an option to buy the thing from him
anytime in the next seven years as a
part of operating it for him I'm
modeling after my little building deal
and you can make it up you can make up a
different narrative a different story
but the point is walk into it don't leap
into it and lay your structure out to do
that yeah I love I the word that keeps
coming to mind is let's practice before
we go to the major leagues let's
practice let's at least take some
batting practice before we realize that
before we decide that's what we're gonna
do forever I love that idea and even if
you can't get a job at a campground in
your local area get a job at um work in
the evening shift at a local hotel
hospitality industry because the
campground history it's tough It's a lot
of people man it's a tough that's a
tough tough gig well and these are you
know if something's broken it's broken
like right then yeah and it doesn't
matter if it's 2 A.M that's right it's
broken if you live on the reason they
let you live on site is because they're
going to come knock they want you to
come get it you are you are the
emergency toilet guy that's your job man
and I mean welcome to doing it that's
part it's okay it's part of the gig and
it's nothing no downside of that except
that that's who it is